the third lesson
is to think deeply to be
quiet and think until
you know the situation you know the
right thing to say
and the right thing to say is the one
that internalizes considers and thinks
through the big picture
of the situation so the emotion you feel
especially when you're young about a
particular situation
the desire to be sort of a crybaby about
things about me me me
about being upset about this situation
or that situation
there was something about the way she
was
quiet and the way she looked over the
world
and the moments when she spoke
were words of wisdom of calm
and patience that was so inspiring
to a mind that was impatient she helped
me understand that the immediate
emotional response to particular
situations the ups and downs of how you
feel
influence the perception the cognition
of how everything is interpreted
and taking your time thinking
being quiet
and speaking when you have something to
say is the kind of man
i should be
you